ومجموعة فاغنر هي التي تقود
حرب بوتين في الوقت الحالي ، فأنا
أحقق التقدم الوحيد المعروف في
ساحة المعركة بالنسبة لبوتين ، وهو ما يعني أن الرجل الذي
يدير أقوى جيش خاص في روسيا
يصنع لنفسه اسمًا هنا
إذا أعلنت جيني باغوزيان علنًا
أن رجاله هم الذين استولوا على
بلدة خارج مدينة باكموف الرئيسية ،
يمكننا أن نقول بأمان أن مستوطنة
كليشيبكا التي تعد واحدة من
أهم ضواحي باكموت قد تم
وضعها بالكامل تحت سيطرة
وحدات فاغنر العسكرية الخاصة بشكل حصري من قبل فاغنر.
تم تحرير وحدات PMC klish ،
إنه أمر لا يصدق حصريًا بواسطة Wagner
Wagner ليس الدفاع الروسي ، إنه
ليس الجيش الروسي ، إنه
مجموعة منفصلة وأنت تؤكد على هذه الكلمة
حصريًا أنه كان هو وليس هم
وأنه يأخذها إلى أبعد من
ذلك  أنتقد علنًا
القادة العسكريين الرسميين في روسيا ، لقد
مررت بأعمق تجربة قتالية
لمدة ثماني سنوات حتى الآن من نواح كثيرة
متفوقة بشكل كبير على تجربة أولئك الذين
عملوا في خدمة
وزارة الدفاع لعقود من الزمان ، إنه أمر
لا يصدق وما هو
مدهش للغاية.  كل هذا إذا
بدا أن فلاديمير بوتين يبدو على ما
يرام معه تمامًا ، وربما لهذا السبب
يسعد السياسيون الروس أيضًا
بدعم بروغوزية في نوع من pregosian
مقابل المؤسسة العسكرية الروسية ،
فقط انظر إلى هذه الصورة من
المشرع الروسي البارز سيرجي
ميرانوف.  أراه هناك ، إنه
يحمل مطرقة ثقيلة ، إنها مطرقة Wagner
Sledgehammer ، هذه صورة استفزازية للغاية
لأن Wagner يتباهى
بوجود المطرقة الثقيلة كرمز
رسمي له ، فلماذا لماذا تم
استخدام مطرقة ثقيلة لقتل
مقاتل من مجموعة Wagner حاول الفرار من
ساحة المعركة  في العام الماضي ، انظر إليه الآن وهو
يلوح به ، وبينما
يعاني الجيش الروسي الرسمي من
نقص في كل شيء إلى حد كبير
مثل الذخيرة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالقتال ، يبدو أن كتابة pagosian
تحصل على المزيد من الأسلحة من نوع
سلسلة التوريد المملوكة بالكامل.  بإلقاء
نظرة على هذه الصور ، سأريكم
هذه الصور التي نفهم أنها
صور لما يبدو أنه عربات قطار روسية
تسافر إلى كوريا الشمالية تلتقط
صواريخ المشاة وأسلحة الصواريخ
التي ، وفقًا للولايات المتحدة ،
انتقلت مباشرة إلى الباغوسيين و
مقاتلات فاجنر في أوكرانيا والقلق
الليلة هو أن كوريا الشمالية قد
ترسل المزيد من المعدات العسكرية الفتاكة
إلى بروغوسيان على وجه التحديد